you said just want to raise a bunch of
children just and like I just want to
point that out because it shows the
mentality of modern women when it comes
to children they don't want to just
raise children they want to raise good
children they want to raise children who
are going to have a good quality of life
and they want to raise children that
don't have to worry about living correct
so children that ride around in their
mum's Range Rover and piss off The
Barley twice a year they're better
children than the kids like me who grew
up on flapins and you know Mom and Dad
were you know screaming at each other
some weekends but other weekends they
were getting along and you know we had a
roast on Sunday we couldn't afford to go
out to bloody The Shard every other